i'm not tapping into any brain just let  me go  tom holland's skills behind the mic are  just as impressive as his on-screen  performances  okay i gotta go bye mom aloft elevaur  a loft eleven oh come on  something smelled wrong and that's  coming from a guy who loves the smell of  butts  someone's been a bad boy there's no  getting past the kalahari snare doc it's  an ingenious design i think you just  caught yourself a boy  in precisely 45 seconds you will  transform into  a pigeon science rocks it's  scientifically proven that watching  kittens causes the enterochromaffin  cells to release serotonin  if i can make you wait for it roll  please  disappear